you okay I'm fine great now what she's
doing right now is she's trying to
accept the fact that she's a podcast
celebrity and and I keep telling her
that because now I go in the road not
the sort of God I go on the road and
people go that listen to Tiger belly go
kalila is kalila here and I just say oh
god you're if people let me see
something right now I'm saying when
people know who you are at will you
haven't met
yeah and they listen to something that
you do yeah that makes you there they're
a fan oh no I
I appreciate them yeah but you're a
celebrity you have to put that on your
Instagram until my pockets are lined
with cash yeah I am NOT the celebrity
unless I can say this is you know a job
and I'm getting some type of like credit
for it from people that actually like
what I have to say oh so what you're
saying that people aren't sending you
money you're not doing other service of
your own heart [ __ ] buckets of cash
you can admit that your sister Joe Rogan
or Bryan Callen or like you know the
Nerdist Chris Hardwick I don't think
you're a podcast live okay we're still
around so what I'm saying right now let
me ask you this when when Brian Brian
and Brendon started partying and they
were starting new why they didn't have
the following they weren't celebrities
they were only celebrities until they
got the following no I think now they're
at a point where they're even worse so
where they were celebrities well Brendon
was because you think you're a celebrity
babe can you stop yeah for sure
climb to can't Twitter tweeter your
belly hashtag Bobby with yeah I get they
accept it I like I you for you're
forcing me you are yeah believing I love
it when lovely when you I was just
talking about having possibly having
Asperger's and you're you're saying that
that's me trying to accept all I know is
dude it's like I just go to towns and
people want to know how you
because I'm your girlfriend and we have
a podcast and they love this it's a
small niche of people I accept that I
think that we have a great tiger belly
family I think we have a very loyal and
dedicated fan base and I love Bill
Clinton's girlfriend is now running for
president girlfriend yeah he was what
she was once his girlfriend which one
Bill Clinton Hillary Clinton somebody
else Monica Lewinsky girlfriend yeah
because at one point they were before
they were before they were married they
were boyfriend and girlfriend Yeah right
so what I'm saying at that stage
oh no right that she would be running
for president oh you were like it's
Paula Jones yeah you say that yeah you
you're celebrities are you ever gonna
like you know put a ring on it well I
mean are you gonna ever have my baby I
want to ask about the three years though
oh there we go that's I love your segue
oh no no we didn't just kill another
baby why are you laughing I'm not
laughing no guys the truth is we had a
scare and I had a very very very late
period and I sincerely thought I was
pregnant for a second and she was and we
talked about it and we aborted another
baby
that's not nice of you to say I didn't
say anything because people aren't gonna
attack you they're gonna attack me I
think I hope I have I don't I'm not
ashamed of my previous abortions I'm
this is my body I get to do whatever I
want like I will say it out loud all day
every day
yeah but um no we didn't just have a
third abortion so sorry that bad second
one yeah that was years ago I just had a
pregnancy scare comedy and also I got a
little fat so we thought for real I was
pregnant and then George was like you
have to keep it it's a great storyline
for tiger belly that's what happened I
had I was having growing a real
Tigra belly a queef
[Music]